wenn man diese anhörungen und jetzt guck
mal da mal genauer ein
mit casey
so wie die tür schon aufgeht dass es
sehr frauenfeindlich nein das ist es
noch nicht
anhörung des angeklagten diese in kürze
gem
sie verzichten auf einen anwalt
vertreten sie silber sie haben das recht
zu schweigen
alles was diese kosten mit welchen weg
ich den polizisten angeschaut habe das
war eine schwulenfeindliche blick nehme
sie aber abfällig schon er war schon was
wollen die mir eigentlich oder nein
warum
das war bis jetzt ist noch alles was ich
sage aus eine anklage puncto tatvorwürfe
zudem nicht so gerne befragen würde
die körperfülle sonst belegt für zu
geringe hemmschwelle da wo ich herkomme
nehmen wir das respekt stelle so viele
besser machen die ein abo zehn gramm
koks und fühlen sich wie rambo aber das
heißt ja zum beispiel genau wie meier
rep anderen das heißt du müsstest
einfach mal die zeilen wiederholen okay
das ist das ist allerdings meine
vergangenheit
das sind ja meine vorstrafen ok zu viele
körperverletzungsdelikte zu geringe
hemmschwelle und da erkläre ich einfach
wie das zustande gekommen ist und zwar
für viel action genau in der
vergangenheit in der vergangenheit war
das war ich so dass ich mir gewisse
dinge nicht gefallen gelassen habe
gefallen lassen habe und das ist ich bin
ein sehr passiver mensch also ich war
noch nie ein typ der jetzt zum beispiel
an dir vorbei gelaufen ist und ich blöd
angemacht hat weil du aufgrund seiner
herkunft hautfarbe brille oder was weiß
ich gar nicht
ich bin total ich bin total korrekt zu
jedem aber das ist leider nicht jeder
und es gibt die leute gegenüber du
manchmal vielleicht vorurteile hast aber
diese asozialen straßen passanten die
gerne in den medien zerrissen werden
könnten so gegen die habe ich auch hass
okay die mag ich selber nicht da bin ich
kein typ der dann wenn man so blöd kommt
oder so mich blöd anmacht oder so dann
war ich in der vergangenheit auf jeden
fall kein typ der dann einfach vorbei
gelaufen ist oder so sondern habt ihr
nicht einfach wenn das bag mit der
rückhand eingezogen und das hast du
wirklich gemacht wirklich und heute ja
nicht mehr oder
jetzt habe ich mit ausgewählten nichts
mehr zu tun okay das heißt du bist nicht
mehr da wo mein respekt stellen
verteilen
doch eigentlich aber aber ich hab das
einfach ich bin erst durch die situation
gibt es einfach nicht mehr
warum nur weil damals war
hängig da ab wo es ärger gab ich war mit
nur mit menschen umgeben wo es eher da
gab ich hab keine rosige vergangenheit
gehabt wie man im sommer aufhört aber
mittlerweile
ich kümmere mich um meine musik ich bin
froh wenn ich zeit mit meinen freunden
mit meinen damaligen freundin auch
verbringen kann
ich bin nur der weg ist doch kein leben
mehr so weiter das war gar nicht so gar
kein leben mehr
oder bedeutet dieses business one hat
dieses business bedeutet autobahn aber
ist er vielleicht besser als
respektierter teilen ihr natürlich das
ist die vergangenheit größten trug mama
wie du dich davon distanziert
nix von respekt ihrem leben ich gehe
allem aus dem weg doch schon nicht wenn
ich seh ich habe wirklich kein interesse
doch leistest du kein widerstand
verwechseln diesen menschen
fähigkeit mit schwäche ok ich hab' ich
habe kein interesse daran
aber wenn man keinen widerstand leistet
gibt es wirklich sehr viele menschen die
höflichkeit mit schwäche verwechseln
sprich wenn ich dich wenn ich oder wenn
du mich jetzt blöd anmacht und ich halte
mein mund und ich sage nichts dann gibt
es wirklich sehr viele menschen die
denken ich habe angst oder ich bin
schwach und umso sind damalige
konfrontationen auch oft entstanden dass
man sich auch beweisen wollte und seine
mutter denkt jetzt nicht ich hab angst
vor di resta okay nur weil ich jetzt
nicht gesagt habe ich will mich über die
stellen der klügere gibt nach ich bin
glücklich denke ich mir glück als nur
irgendwann scheiße ich auf diesen satz
in den klügere gibt nach dann zeige ich
immer mehr links ist gut aber das war
was man macht in seiner jugend wenn man
geräte brauchen guten trend fehlte die
anerkennung in der 6 gegen dabei an der
menschliche projekt nehmen es bis 10
ok zu meinen vorstrafen es geht wieder
um die vergangenheit gehört auch
schwerer fehler gerade gerade diese
sachen weil schwerer raub ist kein
pappenstiel
ich weiß gerade diese sachen sind sachen
wo ich sage heute distanziert
kommt gar nicht auf den trichter
irgendwas in dieser art irgendwann
irgendwas in diese richtung zu machen
weil das ist wirklich nichts schönes
aber ich erkläre es den leuten auch
warum ich das gemacht habe ich war
einfach sehr geld gericht war sehr geld
geld ich wollte geld machen und es gibt
auch in einem umfeld wo ich war gab es
auch immer dieses konkurrenz
konkurrenzdenken dass man gesagt hat du
hast du nicht gehört während der der
gestern die und die aktion gebracht wir
haben wieder raus die also dass und das
hammer krass und dann wollte man was
krasses machen und da hat man dann
natürlich seine fehler gemacht und die
nächste zeile direkt die hast du jetzt
noch nicht laufenberg ich war ein haufen
scheiße ein haufen scheiße heute
ergreife ich seit meinem vater zu mir
meinte mit dem alter kommt die reife
okay da sage ich ich war ein haufen
scheiße heute begriff ist heute begreift
ist als mein vater zu mir meinte mit dem
alter kommt die reife das ist zum
beispiel etwas sehr moralisch total
wertvoll ich finde jeder mensch hat auch
seine vorteile
auf seiner mutter das sind zwar schon
damals nicht getan
nein habe ich nicht in die verzweifelt
in manchen situationen schon klar aber
ich war auch nie so dings so ich konnte
mir das selber gar nicht so richtig er
ich habe auch nie so rein gehört
eigentlich hast du nicht eingesetzt was
meinst du mich reingehört oder hat sogar
ein eltern nicht zugehört oder ich hab
ich habe in diesem krank was dazu gehört
sicher nicht dazu gehört das war
eigentlich nicht ich aber ich denke
jeder mensch ist nicht er selbst wenn in
diesem kreis ist es okay dass der größte
schwachsinn den es auf der welt gibt
einfach unsinnige scheiße zu bauen
und da wird es deutlich ich kann
wirklich nur ans herz legen hört auf
eure eltern weil die
wissen das beste wollen nur das beste
für die oben fällt es gefährlich wie
gesicht erkennt man ja das sind gangster
auch sie können das nicht ändern
wie sie ihr leben es verdammt schwer
trotzdem rückte man nicht alle über
einen kamm scheren und sorgte sein
sportliches wie so geredet ich nehme
kein hintereingang wenn es doch von
vorne geht ist mir egal sie es machen
wie sie meinen aber red devils 100%
schwanz in die scheide
spätestens der frauenfeindlichkeit ich
bin so dominant aber frauenfeindlich
nein
ok ok worüber reden wir jetzt das waren
jetzt schon einige zellen das geht es
geht um das ende der gangstergeschichte
da kommen auch noch mal meine meinung
dazu ist meine meinung dazu ist wenn ich
einen jungen in den arsch [ __ ]
dann wird er nicht schwanger also was
ich was ich doch nicht nur eine meinung
der tatsache dass eine tatsache jetzt
will ich glaube bis jetzt kann man mir
noch kein strick um den hals wegen
diesen satz jetzt das ist die natur
denke ich also die natur mann und frau
vorgesehen dass mann und frau zusammen
gehören wenn mann und frau oder sechs
jahren kommt wenn man jeden fall so
marino von vorne dann kommt man kann's
auch unser garten was kommt gehen daraus
macht und genau was das ist die
menschliche natur
was ist der glaube der glaube ist auch
dass mann und frau zusammen gehören
adam eva prinzip ja wobei das wird es
ist wenn man wirklich sich mit
biologischen oder es gibt in so vielen
tierarten der homosexuelle beziehungen
wie auch immer aber ich gehe nach der
menschlichen natur
die gewünschte die natur ist eigentlich
dass überall wo es geht ja aber
eigentlich eigentlich also ich halte
mich einfach an die einfache variante ob
dann jeder ob jemand die baulust ex oder
in ein loch in diesem tisch macht und
was weiß ich
minister stöger aber ich bin 100 prozent
schwanz in die scheide ok und bin ich
jetzt war durch nachdem ich jeder herz
erklärt haben bin ich nicht ich sage mal
so ist die schwulenfeindlich aber du
bringst mit der esa maskulinen art in
der du four trägst ich sag mal so
niemand kann daraus ableiten dass das
respektiert weil du sagst sollen die
machen was sie wollen oder können wir
mal die stelle gehen war aber was heißt
denn sollen die machen was sie wollen
ist das keines ist das ist nicht
respektvoll
mach doch was du willst wenn man es
normal dramatischer oder deutlicher
formuliert heißt ist mir doch scheißegal
also muss ich sagen ich finds gut da
muss ich sagen es fehlt ich finds gut
sondern du kannst zum beispiel sagen ich
mache so die machen so alles hat seine
berechtigung zum beispiel das mit
berechtigung habe ich nicht gesagt genau
ich muss jetzt nicht komplett diesen
satz aus dem mund wieder geben die
sprache darüber komme ich sage doch man
soll jeder machen wieder bock hat ich
mache es aber so aber hinterher wenn es
auch wohl ist mir egal ist mir egal
sollen sie es machen wie sie es meinen
aber red bull ist 120 scheint das ist
ich habe mir das also ich weiß nicht was
für formen dieser song hätte nehmen
können ich weiß nicht ich gebe nie
bewusst dass dieser song so brisant sein
würde aber ich gehöre jetzt so aber was
ich dir sagen muss ich wusste ganz genau
wie ich die zeile schreiben muss damit
ich mich falsch verstanden werde
also ich habe mir da schon mühe gegeben
dass die leute mich nicht falsch ich
gestehe dazu dass dieser song natürlich
jetzt absolut im fokus und alle gucken
hin und sehen natürlich da auch details
die du vielleicht nicht so gemeint hast
aber die in diesem zusammenhang
vielleicht was anders rüber kommen ein
immer noch nicht akzeptiert nicht
brad pitt ist 100% schwanz in die
scheide
zu gebrauchen freundlichkeit ich bin
dominant war frauenfeindlich nein das
problem ist nur die ko spiele heutzutage
rollentausch zu viele männer haben am
frauen ihren sturz verkauft so das kann
man wirklich als frauenfeindlich sehen
es geht um rollentausch gesagt das kann
nicht sein dass eine frau die rolle
eines mannes einnimmt
was heißt es dann noch männer frau was
haben männer gemacht die haben sich
irgendwie verkauft das problem ist
spielen heutzutage rollentausch zu viele
männer haben am frauen ihren sturz
verkauft das macht frauen wären stolz
verkauft die zeile fängt damit an
äußern sie sehr späte zu der frauenfeind
nicht es geht um mich okay wie ich dazu
schnell und meiner meinung nach ist die
frau frau der man man ich finde frauen
stehen von natur aus auf männer die eine
schützende hand über sie halten können
in meiner welt ist es so ich habe diese
erfahrung gemacht dass frauen schon ein
mann wollen der dominante ist der weiß
was er will der der die richtung weisen
kann der auf der 7 der schützling für
sie hat und das ist ja nicht nur sie ist
ja nicht die einzigste frau wenn kinder
kommen dann irgendwann auch gegenüber
der tochter dass man die tochter auch
beschützen kann und das ist denke ich
auch etwas natürliches also es liegt in
der menschlichen natur den
beschützerinstinkt und alles und diese
dominanz und dann gibt es heutzutage
rollentausch wozu viele männer der frau
ihren stolz verkauft haben aber warum
sollte ich merke gerade wie war dieser
song ist jetzt ist ja weil es gibt so
viele partnerschaftsmodelle wut
gleichberechtigt wo der mann aus mann
ist warum kann der mann nicht aus man
kann er doch dann aber aber dann hat er
scheidet er aus seinen augen den seinen
stolz verkauft aber es gibt frauen die
unterdrücken ihre männer wo wirklich so
die
ist was eigentlich eine frau immer was
eine frau ist also dieses bild einer
frau so einfach der mann dieses bild
erfüllt
wenn männer ihre frauen unter sollten ja
ich sag ja nicht männer sollen ihre
frauen unterdrücken aber männer sollten
schon dominant sein heißt nicht unter
als dominanz und unterdrückung sind zwei
komplett verschiedene paar schuhe
aber es liegt es liegt so eng
beieinander dass man es schon richtig
erklären muss warum england ist ja auch
dominant heißt dominieren das heißt man
ist der erste mann sagt wo es langgeht
und eine partnerschaft da muss noch
nicht einmal sagen wo es langgeht
in meiner partnerschaft ich will der
frau sagen dass ich will das wort haben
ich möchte das gerne sagen aber ohne uns
ohne respektlos zu sein der frau
gegenüber wenn ihr was anderes will ja
dann post ist nicht wer was kann eine
partnerschaft kann ein leben lang ja gar
nicht anhalten die kann ja nur bis die
frau saß mir nicht warum eltern clubs
echt nervt dann hat er hat die frauen
nicht auch ein stolz denken sie daran
den mann verkauft wental übertrieben
meine frau hat seine frau sage ich meine
mutter den größten stolz auf der welt
und sie genauso genauso wie mein vater
die richtung an weist weist sie auch die
richtung zusammen werden entscheidungen
gefällt
zusammen aber du musst dir das
vorstellen wie in einer wg gründen jetzt
eine gesellschaft mit beschränkter
haftung genau wir gründen jetzt eine
eine eine gewehr oder eine gmbh und du
bist gesellschafter mit 49 anteil und du
mit 151 war da mit dem man richtig was
auf 59 prozent sperrminorität ich meine
51% 49 prozent sperrminorität du kannst
nichts machen ohne sich zum stimme
perfekt dass die frau ein das mit 100
ein renner in einer beziehung oder die
frau nicht respektiert die blade nicht
du hast irgendwie hast irgendwann keine
klingt aber anders als in dem video hat
warum ich sage ich hey willst du mich
verarschen geredet ich nehme
hintereingang wenn es auch von vorne
geht
als sie es machen wie sie meinen aber
egal 100% schwarzen direktesten der
frauenfeindlichkeit
ich bin dominant aber frauenfeindlich
nein das problem ist man kaum spielen
heutzutage wollen zu viele männer haben
am frauen ihren sturz verkauft das macht
keinen sinn das erträgt und das gelaber
zum beispiel es nicht bloß wie der
respekt vor meiner mama okay jetzt haben
wir jetzt haben wir alles was wir gerade
gesprochen haben waren in diesen zellen
noch mal drin
und jetzt sagst du zu mir aber in diesem
song klingt es nicht so und jetzt hast
du dir die nächsten 2 soll dank mama die
nächsten vierzehn will es nicht so groß
wie der respekt vor meiner mama sport
ist mein gesetz ihr lächeln ist musik
erleben heißt frieden ihrer tränen
heißen krieg stimmen
und sorgt so für sag ich bin ich jetzt
mal ganz provokant gemein und viel das
ist ja typisch mann mit
migrantenhintergrund alle frauen sind
[ __ ] aus meiner außer meiner mutter
okay du hast die vorteile nicht
natürlich aber ich habe vorteile ist zum
beispiel die vorteile ist das macht
keinen sinn weil ich äußere mich
geradezu der krankheiten stellen das
macht keinen sinn mit der frauen wenn
nicht gar das ist einfach nur trägt man
wenn man sagt ich bin frauenfeindlich
weil wir haben mutter zu hause
wir haben schwester zu hause wir haben
andere und wunderbare frau deines vaters
und ja wir haben andere wundervolle frau
in unserer umgebung die wir die wir
kennen wie soll ich da frauenfeindlich
sein wenn meine mutter eine frau ist
wenn meine schwester in frau ist wenn
meine beste freundin vielleicht kann ich
denn sagen ich verstehe es manchmal auch
nicht ich verstehe manchmal auch nicht
leute die sagen nicht nein du hast dir
wirklich männer die sagen meine mutter
an meine mutter lasse ich nichts dran
aber die alle anderen frauen verachten
so bin ich nicht also nicht nur weil
nicht nur weil ich jetzt eine nein ich
bin einfach nicht so gut fährt sich aus
also er sich sehr erfreulich
hast du jetzt ein besseres mit was
frauen angeht also es wird schließlich
gesagt schon frauenfeindlich ja also das
kommt nicht das kommt schon hier frau
rollentausch und so ich sagte ja und
deswegen ist das video so provokant da
geht gibt es bei vielen leuten auch bei
mir da gehen die nackenhaare hoch gehen
auch aber vielleicht sich dann einfach
solche situationen um mich besser zu
erklären ok wenn die gut dafür ist die
webanalyse da und gar nicht so schlecht
also liebe leute nicht frauenverachtende
immer ihr respekt sagt er
lediglich den stiftung des blutes in
mich rein
diese krisen in meinem bauch ist offen
ob der noch gemeint wenn viel und lass
es raus
dieser typ ist sowie ok da geht es darum
man sagt sie vergiften die jugend und
ich sag nur ein klischee ist neben
lediglich den stift und ich blute
ich will mich einfach von dieser
vorbildrolle auch wenn ich mehr vorbild
bin wie andere artisten will ich mich
davon distanzieren weil es gibt manchmal
sachen wo ich einfach nur den stift
nehmen und schreibe ich brauche das als
künstler diese künstlerische reihe
klassischer niemanden denken muss als
außer an
an diesem moment und mich wie ich gerade
im studio sitzen und in meinem film bin
so und ich will nicht dass das verloren
geht deswegen ob ihr mich als vorbild
nimmt oder nicht
ist euch überlassen aber ich distanziere
mich davon
du bist so wie wir uns scheinen kümmern
sich ja richtig eure kinder packen auf
ihr abi zeigen nur auf mich und sagen
das ist unser abi sie hören auf mich und
höre nicht auf ich sie schreien rippel
als faires hitler durch ok aber da ist
ja genau das thematisiert was genau
machen dass leute dir folgen er aber das
aber das kann ich nicht beeinflussen
soll ich schreiben soll ich sagen nein
folgt mir nicht du kannst sagen folgt
mir nicht da ein sommer folgt ein weißt
du wie viele menschen
warum habe ich so viele klicks in einer
woche dramatisch dramatisch viele
dramatisch viele dramatische spiele weil
ich einen nerv treffen damit die sache
okay vielleicht ist es sehr gut
gelaufene sachen haben vielleicht eine
million klicks in einer woche viel soll
soll so ist komplett durch die decke
gehen soll es 15 millionen klicks
aber wenn wir von 3 mio in einer woche
reden da sind dann habe ich jeden
millionen jetzt ist wann er aber dann
habe ich irgendwann scheint irgendwann
nerv getroffen zu haben
und ich habe ein riesen gefolgschaft
leute die mir folgen aber ich kann es
nicht beeinflussen und das dass ich sage
dass die leute packen kacken auf was
weiß manche menschen gibt es die karten
auf rechts links was sie kennen und wir
sind deren vorbilder
wir sind deren stars absolut sowie
löschen sie möchten sein
wichtiger ist es den ja auch wirklich
ein vorbild umso wichtiger ist es songs
wie anhörung zu machen wie die den
leuten wirklich nur positives naja jetzt
geht es darum dass du dich lieber als
abm als ja wie nein aber dann komme ich
wieder in klicks und auch ich wieder ein
klicks um auf und sagt leute macht euer
abi macht eure schule aber wenn sie
jemanden als vorbild sehen dann sollen
sie können sie mich ruhig als vorbild
sehen aber ich distanziere mich zwar
davon aber immer noch besser wie wendy
vorbild von sensibel sind oder wie wenn
sie vorbild von einem silo sind ja okay
also wenn sie ein vorbild für die ist
gewiss in gewisser weise ist ja
wahrscheinlich auch kein schlechter
vorbild aber der schmerzen zu groß
rändern in wil ein indem er in
irgendwelchen shows sitzt und über
seinen tiefen redet und das gar kein
okay und das würdest du nicht tun
niemals denkst du ist woher das nicht
überlebt ich kämpfe nicht okay ich gebe
für nichtig guckst du nicht manchmal
gibt situationen da trinke ich mal aber
ich mache das auch nicht wenn ihr könnt
weil alles was die sinne benebelt macht
einen menschen halt unberechenbar und
das ist nichts gutes und ich das dann
ziemlich davon einfach aber wenn wenn
ich wenn ich hier so einen schönen song
machte dann werden dann reden die leute
über mich schlecht oder versuchen mich
in den dreck zu ziehen
aber wenn mein sido überredet bei
prosieben dann ist es in ordnung weil
kiffen ist nicht euer feind oder der
feind der medien oder der feind der
gras isst am liebsten würde würde der
redakteur von prosieben der würde am
liebsten am liebsten das kiffen
legalisiert wird
so seien sein feind ist sein feind ist
der der typ der so über frauen redet
versucht das dann so schlecht
darzustellen
das sind ein bisschen links und sagen
wir machen dürfen ist obwohl es der
drogenbesitz oder ich glaube den drogen
ich weiß gar nicht wann darf bestimmte
menge davon bei sich haben aber über
eine bestimmte menge ist halt verboten
ist schon in einer weise in einer
gewissen weise gesellschaften
kooperieren wir auch findest du gipfel
schlimm
ich finds also ich finde wie beim
alkohol viel scheiße wenig gewicht nicht
schlimm
okay dass das sagt es ist eine droge die
mit der man umgehen kann aber natürlich
wie beim alkohol ist kein rapper ich als
rapper ich mache mich verantwortlich
wenn ich solche sachen sage und ich sage
jetzt als gegenüberstellung ich bin
schlimm ich find auch wenig kippen
schnitt also ich sag mal warum ich
erkläre auch warum weil ich will jetzt
nicht zu persönlich schweren aber hast
du kinder
wenn du einen sohn aus dem der elf jahre
alt ist würdest du ihm so oder zwölf
jahre als würde ich ihm sagen nähe so
schlimm ist es nicht
also ich sage mal so ich würde ihm raten
wie zum alkohol auch tue es jetzt nicht
genau und wenn du älter bist in maßen
genau und ich würde ich würde ich würde
mein ich würde region sagen jemand sagt
ich würde mir sozusagen pfiff nicht ja
ich würde auch er rauche nicht ich
trinke nicht genau aber rauchen kann ich
ganz fremd zu sein
ich bin im interview ich rufe dich
zurück
liebe grüße an mode aber ich sage ich
dann ziemlich häufig sah gekifft nicht
warum weil wenn du deinen honigtau nach
seinem sohn nicht nicht sagst dann warum
vor warum vor der kamera schauen so
viele zwölfjährige zu so viele
13-jährigen 14 15 jährige so viele leute
die nie
gekifft haben und dass vielleicht sagen
du kannst bestimmte dinge nicht
verhindern ist beginn dinge und da gibt
es viel schlimmer weil sie verboten da
wird noch extensiver gemacht ich glaube
wenn man drogenfrei gibt die hände das
kommt drauf an wer es verbietet werde
ich finde wenn ich es denn ich es wenn
ich es verbietet dann vielleicht nicht
die drei millionen die in der ersten
woche das video zugeschaut haben aber
vielleicht bei einem fluss sich eine
million dateien ich will das kreativ es
ist natürlich ist kiffen genauso wie
alkohol trinken furchtbar alkohol
zerstört gehirnzellen man wird wirklich
blöde davon und kiffen blockiert
gehirnzellen das thc drin und ich habe
wirklich leute gesehen die ordentlich
gekifft haben die sind komplett durch
ein also richtig erklären bled durch den
wind das ist schlimm passt richtig ich
will es nicht ich sage mal ich möchte
ich sagen tut es auf keinen fall
damit sie es dann doch tun und in einem
maße dass sie eben komplett durch den
recht über lernt mit drogen umzugehen
nützt sie nicht aber die drogen sind
dafür und jetzt nicht mehr wegdenken
das schlimme ist christel messe zum
beispiel der rookie war darüber
branchenriesen hohem niveau katastrophen
die sind aber auch wirklich
lebensgefährlich aber aber jetzt kommt
noch mal jetzt kommt noch mal noch ein
weiterer faktor ist auch wichtig wo du
sagst also wenn du es wenn es hierbei
klebten wer mir klicks und darüber reden
finde ich es nicht so schlimm wie wenn
man in prosieben darüber rede weil da
sind wirklich einmal nur menschen
ich kiffe nicht ganz klar ich kann ich
keinen spaß dran
hast du schon mal gekifft ja einmal ich
habe auch ein paar mal habe ich auch
schon mal mit wenig offen drüber
und ich sage das größte scheiß nein ich
sag mal also mir gefällt ihm ständig
lang weil ich weil ich glaube
wenn man als mensch wenn man sich wenn
man selbst sein will also wenn man eine
person sein will sollte man keine drogen
nehmen weil kosten soll
man macht sich zum nichts mehr addiert
sich aus und deswegen hast du unterricht
schlecht deswegen sage ich macht lieber
sport macht eure schule geht geht raus
trefft euch mit mädchen kick drum selbst
das expert of pop selbst selbst dass
selbst das passt nicht zu meinem glauben
ja ich bin nicht perfekt bin ich nicht
auch das passt nicht nur im glauben
nicht machst du jetzt denkst ich rede
jetzt nur noch ich bin ein typ der nur
noch meinen blumen geb ich mach
ständiger auch leider kurz aber immer
noch besser wie wenn ihr gift wenn ihr
besoffen in irgendeinem bahnhof am
samstag nacht schrecklich ich
verabscheue das also ich würde auch
sagen keine harten drogen nie zu viel
und am besten um ausprobieren
unterlassen oder gar nicht kommt sonst
kommen wir nie zu ende
wir gucken nochmal jetzt wird warum
nicht ich bin kein krimineller drogen
kehren und auch kranke sowie sieht
der sie verleitet nur ab und zu würden
dennoch nie geht scheiße ich habe auch
probleme ich hab auch familie meine
existenz ich hab auch mal krisen und
warum können sie über von nahezu frei
machen
sorry ja ich sage einfach weil die
vorteile war ja die kids zeigen mit
ihrem finger und sagen was unser abi
dass ich einfach diese person bin den
sie denen die leute hinterher iphone
gewisse menschen meine hörerschaft selbe
spiel ich bin nicht unbedingt ein
vorbild aber wenn ich ein vorbild bin
warum nicht weder bin ich jetzt gerade
wieder bin ich jetzt kriminell
weder bin ich drogen typ weder fordere
ich die leute auf scheiße zu machen oder
sonstwas wie andere da er wenig auch als
beispiel einen anderen rapper die andere
rapper viel über den magath gesprochen
genau wenn ich dann mal was sage was
vielleicht nicht eins zu eins
vorbildliches dann weil ich auch gefühl
haben ich schreibe auch meinen text wo
ich wo ich ein liebeslied schreibe und
sagen meine ex hat mich die all hat mich
geschickt diese oder was weiß ich und da
sind wir wieder im hip hop dass das pop
hiphop hat auch eine gewisse härte das
mache ich nicht weil ich frauen
verschwinden aber auch aus mir kommt
manchmal auch negative sachen aber warum
ja gesagt so distanziert sich dann im
flexo männer waren ja was soll ich
machen
ich kann es nicht jedem recht machen
wenn es teilen gibt die einige falsch
verstehen dann verstehen sie die falsch
da haben sie mir einfach nicht begriffen
oder hast du es auch angelegt hatte die
falsch verstehen können ich tue mein
bestes das mich dass ich richtig
verstanden werde
ich habe sehr klare sehr klare
textzeilen gerade in diesem song auch
und wenn es dann leute gibt die mich
falsch verstehen dann versuche ich mich
noch mal zu erklären wie ich das jetzt
machen wir machen eine web analyse
analysiert jede zeile gut dann geht das
ist doch
andere rapper machen es mir einfach lebt
erzählt was von gerlos reden respektlose
lebens eingesetzt los alles nur zum
reden sohn straßen deutsch
doch sturm boss war mit dem moneyball
was ich mit meinem boss was vor
meinungen sich scheiden
da geht es um diese rapper klischees ich
weiß nicht wie die zellen gefunden
ich wollte ihn endlich zu brei machen
ach so ja der richter fragt mich warum
ich rapper namentlich zu drei mache
warum ich rap namen erwähnen oder warum
ich mich abfall nicht gegenüber anderen
rappern rapper äußern weil ich bin ich
mag diese ich mag ich mag diesen
gangster möglich ich bin auch immer ist
das nicht gangsta rap überhaupt nicht
überhaupt nicht warum nicht warum es den
gangsta-rap weil die leute es geht ja um
verbrechen und neuner jugend gemacht
hast ein rap dem man in der rolle eines
gangsters oder oder warte ich geb dir
widerlege das noch mal ganz kurz zum
teil schon ein bisschen ok aber was ich
sagen wollte ich ich bin kein gangster
rapper schon aber ich habe sehr viele
facetten und gangsterrap ist die einer
der kleinsten davon aber ich mag es
einfach nicht diese ganzen leute die aus
irgendwelchen davonkommen wir leben in
deutschland wir haben für jedes problem
eine institution die uns zur hilfe steht
ob sozialamt ob jobcenter wohngeld
kindergeld und was weiß ich was herrn
geld kriegen so viel hilfe hier und wir
müssen viele sachen gar nicht machen
gerade was ich in der vergangenheit
gemacht aber ich musste die sachen nicht
machen musste ich nicht das war mein
luxus problem aber es gibt ja auch mehr
ich sag mal so wie in den achtzigern
gedacht doch es gibt natürlich härter
auf der straße allerdings da und es gibt
die gangster waren oder die diese härte
entsteht nicht aus einer sozialen not
oder so bei uns nicht deswegen habe ich
schon mal irgendwie interview gesagt
glaubt dass die meisten gangster hier in
deutschland hobby gangster sind sie habe
keinen bock zu arbeiten irgendwie anders
wahr was zu reißen so und deswegen
machen die irgendwas muss vielleicht ein
bisschen schneller geht wie ich auch
damals mit wie ich mit 16 geschickt habe
so dass ich schnell aufgebracht und
einige leute mit 26 36 immer noch nicht
auf fragen wie viele jahre war nach wir
haben aufgemacht
vor 45 jahren
und das war nach wie viel jahren also
mit 16 angefangen war nicht so dass ich
nun richtigen arbeitsablauf die achte
auf heute geht es in dem schreiben nicht
ganz weg wo andere nur deutsch habe ich
am 9
ok und habe ich schlecker ok als zwei
stunden schlecker ich werde am ende
gezogen
nein nein also ich mag einfach nur nicht
diese rapper die dann einfach die ich
auch zu 90 prozent alle kennen und zu 99
prozent von den 99 prozent auf alle
doppelten aber übertrieben auch sagen ja
verrät es gibt viele die dings die cool
sind aber gerade von diese straßenrap
schiene die leute die dann so erzählen
ich bin so und so habe ich einfach so
viele leute kennengelernt die wirklich
einfach nur richtige pizza sind und die
das aber
anders darstellen und dann bin ich halt
ein typ der seinen mund aufmacht
ich mache was sagen alle hatte den mund
aufmachen sich nicht verbieten lassen
und ja aber ich kann es am ich kann es
am besten wieder legen ich bin casey
rebell guck mal wie ich meinen mund
aufmache
doch auf irgendeine weise war die chance
meine meinung für einigkeit in form von
millionen von klicks für kurzen
augenblick war meine vision so geprägt
ich fühlte mich im namen von brett so
beleidigt musste den leuten zeigen sie
verdreckt es so freundlich schickt ihn
backstage hobby mike das web auf dem
stempel ist ein thema für sich
was ich da gibt es eigentlich nicht zu
analysieren weil er nichts falsch
verstanden also wie ich es im song sage
ich habe den ball lieber eine grube
gegraben
da wird er nicht mehr raus aus dem
geschäft garn oder war es ja irgendwann
war irgendwann mal hast du bestimmt was
von ihm gehört oder interviewt er war
okay und dann ganz bestimmt eine zeit wo
du nichts mehr von ihm gehört das
richtig das war richtig gut
wie ist das überhaupt manche haben ja
ich meine sido ist nach wien gefahren zu
treffen eko fresh hat mit ihm was
zusammen gemacht gesteht ich nicht also
wer wirklich nach sophie kilometer fährt
um jemanden zu sehen muss wie möglich
nicht alle latten am zaun deine meinung
lagerhäuser
und wir alle wissen doch
alles zum schwimmen gegen das system an
ich sterbe doch verkaufe meine seele
nicht den start
widerstand lieber für dich jeden tag
anstatt marionette zu sein und du was
man mir sagt ich drücke mich nicht
selber dass wir ehren los ich bin rebell
ich bin der gegenpol und wenn ich ab
morgen keine platte mehr verkauf ist das
schade doch kann vor mein spiegel sind
überhaupt nicht war gerade beendet als
bürger haben fest und genau so haben
gesetze
lieber respektieren und schützen also da
stellst du dich ja schon relativ
deutlich gegen das gericht auch wenn du
nicht sagst ich akzeptiere die ich nicht
aber du sagst ich bin ich und ich mache
mein ding und das vor gericht zeugen
schon vor dir
ich bin ich mache was ich will ich mache
was ich will ich will ich denke ich aber
was die schwachen und lang konnten dann
würde ich dann weiter sah weil wird dies
weiter ziehen und sagen schaut ja und
das heißt der scheiß auf gericht nein
was ich mache und was ich sage
muss ja nicht das kann ja auch mit dem
das können wir auch mit dem ich lebe ein
ruhiges leben
aber so wie du dich da aber wenig im rat
und ich mag es ging nicht darum aber
wenn ich etwas wenn ich was sage ich
meine wer wer soll diesen widerstand
dieses rebellische mehr verkörpern hätte
ich stelle das als künstlername ich bin
einfach das ist ein grund warum ich das
als künstler habe ich bin ein sehr auf
ständiger rebellischer mensch schwimme
ich will gegen den ich schwimme gegen
den strom vielleicht auch durch meine
durch meine engstirnigkeit vielleicht ja
vielleicht nicht weil ich jetzt
irgendjemand wieder abgezogen habe oder
jemand umgebracht habe oder einen
schweren job gemacht habe oder was weiß
ich vielleicht sogar wegen dieser
geschichte
ja man versucht mir daraus einen strick
zu drehen aber diesen in deutschland und
das ist doch das gesetz also wenn wir
doch nach dem gesetz leben das hier ist
künstlerischer meinungsfreiheit
mir wird da nichts passieren kann nichts
passieren
okay das war's wohl
was ergänzen
guben forst berichten ja schickt den
richter nur gott kann mich richtig
ja und da sind ja wohl eindeutig fig den
richter aber für den richter ach so ok
ja ja einen 1 für eine fiktive person
ich habe gesagt die richter ja ja ich
habe ihnen gemeint er ist kein
schlechter schauspieler glaube ich gar
nicht mehr reden wollte haben die
wirklich die ersten 20 30 minuten nur
über die zweite herren was soll ich
versucht mich an zu zeigen versucht mich
versucht den song zu verbieten
das einzigste was die machen können ist
wirklich das einzigste was was mir
wirklich passieren kann ist dass mein
album auf dem index landet nicht wegen
sowas doch die versuchen das gerade ein
land da hast du ja recht dass kunst und
du darfst du in deiner kunstform nicht
sagen was du willst
wenn ich hier immer berufs nicht zu
gewalt auf aber wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel sondermodelle hattest du ja
recht das einzige was ich argumentiere
ist dass der zusammenhang zwischen text
und bild das suggeriert aber den text
für sich sagt er nicht bringt richter um
ich ja ja aber wenig stoff wodurch das
video mit auf den kauf der cd dvd wurden
video mit drauf ist das nicht aber es
gibt ja auch schon harmlosere sachen
also das wird er richtig so gerade die
versuche mich gerade wenn man jetzt
darüber so reden kann wie die versuche
mich an ständigen beleidigungen
verleumdungen und was weiß ich was und
versuchen daraus einen strick zu drehen
und das index hat sich auch schon
eingeschaltet
also das wäre eine katastrophe wenn es
auf dem index landen ja darf nicht auf
dem ladentisch sein du musst du musst
zum verkäufer hingehen und sagen ich
hätte gerne das album von basic banger
rebelliert er richtig natürlich ist das
eine katastrophe
online darf nicht mehr verkauft werden
also rate ich den leuten geht am dritten
fünften in den laden und als einer der
ersten person weil es wirklich gerade
danach aussieht dass es infiziert werden
kann
es kann auch sein dass es nicht
indiziert wird aber ich gerade schon
okay schnell zugreifen freunde menge
rebellieren dritter fünfter bin darf ich
im marketing
ja und dann gehst du die richter heben
die hände
in erwartung jetzt abgeschossen zu
werden und dann blendet supplies to be
continued
man könnte fast meinen wenn man das
anschließende videos sieht in der du die
zeitung mit den berichten in der hand
mit den berichten der anteil über dieses
video dass es alles geplant gewesen nein
ehrlich du erwartest jetzt noch lassen
aber nein gibt es nicht also es gibt
keiner weiß wann ich es war nicht
geplant hatte die video firma auch gar
nicht so vor dass ich die zeitung
aufschlage
die zeitung ist rausgekommen wie du
drehtag okay das heißt die videofilme
wusste gar nicht dass das ist jetzt auf
einmal wachsen in zeitungsstand damit
ich einfach mit der bild bekommen habe
ich gesagt guck mal genau das werden wir
jetzt machen warum nicht gut
vielen dank